willkommen zur heutigen sitzung der wir
uns mit dem problem des hasses befassen
werden
diese emotionen ich hatte schon der
letzten sitzung als wir es ebenfalls
problematischen evolution mit neid und
eifersucht zu tun hatten gesagt dass es
auch normativ problematische emotionen
gibt nicht nur das kreativ interessante
emotionen die wir davor schon
kennengelernt hatten
man soll eben auch sehr problematischen
und dazu zählt eben vor allem auch die
hass in der aktuellen debatte kennen wir
solche probleme mit wie krebs pietsch
wie hass verbrechen und so weiter und
wir wollen jetzt also der heutigen
sitzung untersuchen inwiefern der hass
eine philosophische interessante emotion
ist und ich gehe noch mal kurz auf den
plan des seminars ein um zu zeigen wie
der hass sich im gesamten seminarplan
befindet wir hatten in der letzten
sitzung neid und eifersucht anhand von
aristoteles und kann in der heutigen
sitzung geht es um hass als hatte und
noch ein kurzer ausblick auf den hass
nach max scheler in der nächsten sitzung
behandelt mir die liebe anhand von
augustinus und seiner rezeption durch
ein arendt und in der letzten sitzung
dieses semesters noch mal den begriffen
die emotionen der liebe an der
philosophie von händels zeit so viel zum
seminar planen jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
zurück zur letzten sitzung das ist eine
allegorie von peter beucke diesem
renaissance-maler der hier den neid sehr
bildhaft und eindrücklich darstellt hier
haben wir sowas nie eitelkeit und hier
zeigt eine person auf dieses gefühl
dieses vogels was man so als ein
vergleich mit einer anderen person
ansehen könnt der als ungerecht
empfunden wird
hier kann man jede menge noch an details
finde ich will da auch gar nicht länger
angehen oben rechts ist der link zur
letzten sitzung und wir den neid
ausführlich erlernt haben und jetzt gebe
ich noch mal eine kurze zusammenfassung
unserer ergebnisse also weit besteht
nicht bereits darin dass eine person
eine person b um ein bestimmtes gut sie
beneidet weil sie dies gerne hätte das
sind ja gemeinhin als neid verstanden
anders denn gefällt es sich der neue
kommt seine ganze moralische problematik
und auch seine emotionale struktur die
hochinteressant ist dadurch dass die
neidische personal gründe sucht und
scheinbar findet welche personen bewegen
c des gutes in einem schlechten licht
zeigen dass sie aus der sicht von
personal nicht verdient dass es ist
immer damit nicht nur ein begehren
verbunden etwas zu haben was man nicht
hat das wäre noch nicht neid organische
problematischen sinne der nis kunst das
muss dazu noch eine überlegung kommen
die die personen die dieses gut hat in
einem schlechten licht erscheinen lässt
so dass die person die neidisch ist sich
gerechtfertigt ein anspruch zu erheben
auf dieses gute 10
diese suchen nach möglichen gründe doch
auch berechtigt zu sein das gut zu
gesetzen zeigt dass sehr viel destruktiv
irrationalität und spielst ja es total
es richtig bemerkt findet man nur da
statt wo es eine basis für vergleiche
gibt personen die sich in sehr
verschiedenen positionen befinden werden
dann das seltener als wöchentlich
gespielt ich werde zum beispiel bill
gates wegen seines großen vermögens
sicherlich nicht bereit einfach deswegen
alles keine vergleichsbasis er macht
etwas ganz anderes als die ich er ist
viel älter als ich und so weiter und so
fort
es wäre absurd ihm bleiben zuvor
sicherlich kann ich ihnen seines
reichtums bewundern oder auch schätzen
aber wirklich gründe night zu sein
ergeben sich hier nicht oder nur sehr
schwer aber der eifersucht finden sie
strategien eine andere person ein
schlechtes licht zu rücken um die gunst
einer geliebten person sehr wohl haben
und zu verhalten
hier stellt sich mir vor allem die frage
auf was jetzt die eifersucht als emotion
gerichtet ist auf die geliebte person
oder die geschätzte person deren
künstlich besitzen möchte auf die gunst
ihrer person oder auf eine andere person
die die kunst an sich zieht und medicus
zu nehmen scheint also hier kann man
noch viel drüber diskutieren
so jetzt komme aber auf den hass genauer
zu sprechen wieder anhand von konnte
diesmal aber nicht über seine schrift
der ekel ich mache oben rechts mit einem
link zu dieser sitzung ein wenig besser
behandelt haben sollen dieses mal eben
aus einem philosophischen hauptwerk das
war das nichts aus dem jahr 1943
und zwar bringe ich jetzt ein paar
zitate die zeigen wie sah das nicht nur
ein gefühl charakterisiert sondern
gewissermaßen als eine existenzielle
einstellung oder auch eine metaphysische
ein stückchen fasst die das andere
zugeht betrifft ich habe mitleid fragen
wie definierte sator den hass inwiefern
ist hat eine emotion durch ein besitzer
hat eine rationale eine motivation ahlen
eine phänomenale zeit
inwiefern ist das moralisch
problematisch welche form von eis gibt
es die verhalten sich hass und liebe max
scheler auf dem wir ganz am ende der
sitzung noch kurz eingehen werden das
zitat nachsaat du hast nimmt dich vor
keinesfalls mehr objekte seien und er
hasst bietet sich als eine absolute
setzung der freiheit das für sich
gegenüber dem anderen da deshalb vor
allem erniedrigte hast das gehasste okay
nicht wenn er versetzt die
auseinandersetzung auf ihre richtige
ebene was ich am anderen hasse ist nicht
irgendeiner physiognomie ein tick
irgendeine besondere handlung ist es
zeigen existenz schlechthin als
transzendiert transzendenz deshalb
implizierte hast eine anerkennung
der freiheit des anderen nur es diese
anerkennung abstrakt und negativ der
hass kennen nur den objekt andern und
hält sich an dieses objekt dieses objekt
will er zerstören und gleichzeitig die
transzendenz von der s heimgesucht wird
zu beseitigen
diese tendenz wird nur erahnt als
unerreichbares jenseits als fortwährende
entfremdung möglichkeit ist für sich
dass hass sowie haben wir jetzt ganz
verschiedene passagen also es geht hier
ist und das 40 das ist so eine typische
kenianische rede das an sich das für
sich das für sich könnte man auch als
die subjektivität bezeichnet es geht um
das subjektivität gegenüber einem
anderen für sich also einem
gewissermaßen objekt als subjekt was ich
mir gegen stellen hier kann man jetzt
verschiedene weitere charakterisierungen
vornehmen also der hass der gilt nicht
irgendeiner besonderheit dieses anderen
sondern gilt dem gesamten für sich im
andern und hier sehen wir jetzt eine
gewisse spannungen existenzielle
spannung die zwischen zwei freien zu
klicken auftreten
es ist praktisch die existenz des
anderen alt etwas was ich nicht nur
objektivieren lässt und was in einer
gewissen weise als einschränkung meiner
freiheit empfindet und er zeigt aber
sagen dass diese einschränkung ich
empfinde deswegen ich das andere zur
kasse
zugleich eine anerkennung dessen
freiheit einschließt aber diese
anerkennung ist wie sagte weiter
ausführt subjektiv und abstrakt negativ
dass heißt sie ist nicht positiv im
sinne des wohlwollens sind es eine
negative anerkennen
das wäre praktisch astrid die
charakterisierung des hasses und zwar
eben insofern dass andere subjekt als
objekt angesehen wird
das zerstört werden soll
um diese transzendenz anders mal diese
subjektivität das andere zu beseitigen
ja das ist jetzt eine sehr abstrakte
charakterisierung kann man sagen wir
wollen jetzt genau noch ein bisschen
weiter eingehen was ich hasse sagt sagte
weiter ich die gesamte psychische
totalität insofern sie mich auf die
transsib dieses anderen verweist also
psychisch nicht physisch seelische
subjektive seite
ich lasse mich nicht dazu haben ein
besonderes objektiv ist details lassen
darin liegt der unterschied zwischen
hassen und verabscheuen
und das erscheint nicht notwendig
anlässlich eines übels ich erlitten
haben er kann im gegenteil da entstehen
wo man zu recht anerkennung erwarten
kann das heißt anlässlich einer wohltat
der anders der den hass hervorruft ist
einfach die handlung des anderen durch
die in den zustand versetzt worden bin
seine freiheit zu erleiden diese
handlung als solches demütigend sie ist
die mutter liegt als konkrete
entwicklung meiner instrumenten objekt
gegenüber der freiheit das andere
also haben wir jetzt verschiedene punkte
bitte es gilt nicht der hass gegenüber
der physischen realität der physischen
existenz in der psychischen totalität
die eben seine subjektivität des anderen
kannte sie transzendenten die
beschreitung die bloßen gegebenheit des
bösen objektiven satellit an später
genauer erläutern worin diese transnet
versteht kurz gesagt ist die negativität
also deswegen heißt auch das buch das
sein dass nicht transzendenz bedeutet
eben das gegebene regieren zu können
dadurch hebe ich nicht über dieses
gegebene dem ich den raum der
möglichkeiten betrete ich kann sagen es
könnte auch ganz anders sein
und darin liegt auch meine freiheit und
jetzt gibt es eben das problem dass sich
mir in meiner transzendenz ein anderes
sortiment geben stellt was mich
gewissermaßen transferiert und aus
dieser spannung da entsteht
gewissermaßen als effekt der hass noch
eine schöne unterscheidung von hassen
und verabscheuen die verabscheut die
gilt ein bestimmten objektiven detail
der hass gilt diesen subjekt dem anderen
zug liegt was mich transzendiert und
mich gewissermaßen zu einem klick macht
mich gewissermaßen auch negiert das ist
die wurzel des hasses und als solche
wird geben die das transzendiert werden
durch das andere als dem gegend erfahren
also meine instrumentelle mobilität
gegenüber der freiheit das andere könnte
auch sagen die srg sich gekränkt weil
ein gewisser narzissmus zu sehen wir
wollen dass gleich weiter untersuchen
aber an des nächsten tages sagte weiter
der andere dem ich hasse repräsentiert
in wirklichkeit die anlage
entwurf interessen ist der entwurf den
anderen schlecht firmen zu beseitigen
das heißt meine nicht substanzielle
freiheit eines für sich zurück zur im
haus ist ein verständnis dafür dass
meine in fremd institution an reale
knechtschaft ist die mit dichten anderen
geschnitten
seit dieser gesellschaft ist
beabsichtigt warum ist der haus- hast
ein schwarzes das heißt ein gefühl dass
es auf die beseitigung eines anderen
abzielt und dass ich als entwurf bewusst
gegen die missbilligung der anderen
entwirft den hass den der andere auf
einen anderen lädt das billige ich damit
unglücklich und ich suche ihn zu
beseitigen
denn wenn er sich auch nicht
ausdrücklich gegen gerichtet so weiß ich
doch dass er mich betrifft und er sich
gegen nicht realisiert und er ist
tatsächlich darauf aus mich zu zerstören
nicht in sofern er nicht gegen sucht
soll insofern ein grundsätzlich meine
missbilligung verlangt und sich darüber
hinwegsetzt zu können der hass verlangt
gehasst zu werden so für einen hassen
einer besorgten anerkennung der freiheit
des passenden gleichkommt was sind jetzt
sehr viele informationen ich hatte
wichtigsten passagen jetzt mal gelb
markiert es geht nicht um den anderen
diesen konkreten individuellen anders
geht um die andere subjektivität als
zeichen und da zeit gezahlt hast ist das
bedürfnis den anderen schlecht hin zu
beseitigen und meine freiheit der
subjektivität zurückzuerobern im haus
sehe ich meine eigene freiheit bedroht
und reagiere darauf gewissermaßen in
einer form der negieren das andere
ich bin von knechtschaft also man fühlt
sich im hass geknechtet und möchte gegen
die impfung knechtschaft reagieren
durch das antizipieren das ist ein
schwarzes gefühl dass jetzt eine
phänomenologische unterschreiben
dh auf die bezeichnung eines anderen
abzügen regierungen die wiesen grasen
auf die zerstörung die da eine
wunschbilder es hat etwas
zerstörerisches kann man allgemein sagen
wie geht es weiter seit folgendermaßen
weiter über den hass zitat der hass ist
seinerseits ein scheitern
sein ursprünglicher entwurf ist ja die
anderen bewusst seine zu beseitigen also
das für sich ist das bewusstsein nati
transzendieren drittel zu beseitigen die
mich dran ziehen ihren aber selbst wenn
ihm das gelingen das heißt sie den
anderen gegeben werden moment vernichten
könnte könnte er doch nicht machen dass
der antrag nicht genießen sie geht um
die existenz
mehr noch da die vernichtung des anderen
als der triumph des hasses er liebt wird
impliziert sie die ausdrückliche
anerkennung dass der andere existiert
hat folglich wird man für andere sein
wenn es in die vergangenheit sind alle
unabänderliche dimension meiner selbst
es ist das was ich zu sein haben als es
gewesen sein ich kann mich an nichts von
ihm befreien
wenigstens wird man sagen hingehe ich
ihm in der gegenwart werde ich ihm in
der zukunft energie aber nein der einmal
für andere bewiesen ist ist in seinem
seien für den rest seiner tage
kontrollieren auch wenn der angriff
völlig bis heute thrombin er wird auch
weitere institutionen des für anderes
als eine permanente möglichkeit seines
seins erfassen also satte zeigt ja
gewissermaßen eine dialektik des hauses
auf also es ist so dass selbst wenn ich
den anderen hass und vernichten möchte
immer noch selbst wenn ich ihn
vernichtet habe ich anerkennen muss das
rx
hirt hatte denn sonst hätte ich ja gar
nicht irgendwann nicht oder hassen
können also der hass kann den anderen
gar nicht vollständig wenn nicht gerade
im hassen des anderen anerkennen ich
muss ihn ja als ein ok suchen zu
vernichten hier ist natürlich ein bezug
zu hegels herr knecht dialekt gegeben an
die auch diesen sachverhalten von zwei
zugängen die problematischen
konfrontativen verhältnissen sie
anschaulich zeigt ich möchte darauf aber
nicht genauer noch eingehen das würde zu
weit führen
so jetzt kommen wir auf dem nächsten
denker versprechen die wir schon hatten
nämlich auf max scheler ich nach oben
rechts den link zur der sitzung in der
es um die scham nach schüler gehen
hinein jetzt aber geht es um wir sind
von der sympathie und insbesondere um
huston liebe schüler sagt freundes
zunächst ist liebe und hass nicht etwas
zu unterschieden das heißt nur die liebe
nicht da sein eine sache wäre das ist
vielmehr ein positiver akt in dem ebenso
nun wird gegeben die ist wie immer der
liebe ein positiver wirkt während aber
lieber eine bewegung ist die vermieter
und zuhören wird geht und in der
jeweilige höhere wert eines gegenstandes
oder eine person ihres zu aufblitzen
kommen ist er hasan entgegengesetzte
bewegung damit ist auch ohne weiters
gegeben dass das auf die mögliche
existenz des niedrigeren mehr das
gerichtet ist
die als solche selbst ein negativer wert
ist und auf die aufhebung von der
möglichen existenz des höheren wertes
die wiederum ein negativer wert ist
liebe aber richtet sich auf die setzung
des möglichen höheren wert ist die
selbst ein hörer selbst positiver wert
ist bzw erhaltung des höheren wertes und
auf aufhebung des möglichen niedrigeren
wertes ihr selbst ein positives licht
wert ist die hast also durchaus nicht
ein bloßes sich abschließend gegen das
gesamte reich gewährt werden
er ist vielmehr mit einem positiven hin
blicken auf den möglichen niedrigeren
werten verknüpft anders als seite der
den hass als befasst existenzielles
betrachtet betrachtet schiller den hass
im rahmen seiner wehr tätig sondern
material wird also werte existieren
verschiedene objektiv ist nicht nur
subjektive konvention alis tische gegen
sensibilisieren objektiv und hass in
diesem sinne eine einstellung eine
internationale einstellung zu einem
niedrigen zu einem negativen wert gehe
aber im sinne des aktes in sind des
aktes ein positiver fakt ist weil er
eben fanden sich auf etwas richtet auf
etwas objektiv richtet aber eben nicht
auf einen wert sind auf einen wert jetzt
kann man sich überlegen was ist denn ein
unwerth auch immer dann müsste man jetzt
genau das ist das suchen aber jedenfalls
hier ist der punkt dass hass und liebe
geht es mal gegenläufig sind aber
insofern wiederum verwandt sind als es
beides internationale einstellungen sind
zu wert auf der einen seite betriebe und
und wird im falle dass es so dass noch
kurz neben zu schiller und jetzt komme
ich noch kurz auf einen ausblick der
nächsten sitzung da geht es um die liebe
bei augustinus und bei einer abend und
ich denke auch dass wir hier sehr sehr
spannend darüber diskutieren können wenn
sie kommentare haben gerne unten im
video
ich freue mich
auf jeden kommentar dann wünsche ich
alles gute
und wir sehen uns in der nächsten
sitzung